all right Mike Marshawn thank you guys  for coming to this meeting we're just  trying to figure out what happened  Sunday yeah no problem so how are Mike's  grades Mike's well this is a parent  teacher conference isn't it I mean I've  been making Mike my son for years now  you're so corny I'm gonna throw up he's  just mad I took away his Xbox you threw  a tantrum because Brady called you mean  names but I'm the child yeah okay okay  enough just tell me what happened  Marshawn told Tom he's too old to be  playing this game and that he needs to  go home and spend time with his wife and  kids because these are yours he'll never  get back and he'll regret not seeing  them grow up just to pursue an eighth  Championship which is objectively  excessive his words not mine oh oh God I  regret nothing and then Tom called him  and well you saw the rest okay this  sounds like it didn't really have that  much to do with you yeah so why did you  deck Marsh on that oh I just don't like  it [ __ ] you